hello and welcome to the daily climate
show coming up
homes with electric cars and heat pumps
are saving more than a thousand pounds a
year as inflation continues to rise
europe's most powerful electric charging
hub has opened in oxford with the
capacity to recharge a car in 20 minutes
and a year's worth of rain in three days
around sydney leaves 50 000 people
facing evacuation from their homes
hello and welcome to the daily climate
show where we track the changes
happening to our planet hear from the
people hit hardest by those changes and
reports on the race for solutions now we
start the show with an exclusive about
the amount of money being saved by
households using electric cars and heat
pumps and the good news is you'll be
making big savings compared to
households using petrol or diesel or gas
spoilers so let's take a look at the
numbers for you now the research by the
energy and climate intelligence unit has
found that households with fossil fuel
cars and gas boilers are spending 1180
pounds more each year than their
electric counterparts and with inflation
uh that's almost doubled from 620
from last year and this extra spending
is expected to rise to 1 600 pounds in
october and when the energy price cap
rises again well joining me now from the
scottish highlands to talk through this
is simon crane mcgreen head of analysts
at the eciu simon thanks so much for
joining us my first question is what do
you make of those savings
thanks for having me
these savings illustrate what households
are painfully aware of which is that
over the past year the price of fossil
fuels has soared and this has had a huge
knock-on effect on on bills
and the only real way to avoid the pain
of fossil fuel prices is to stop using
them whether house households or
nationally
and as you pointed out there an electric
household with a heat pump an electric
vehicle and better insulation was
already saving over 600 pounds a year on
energy bills last year
and the office of national statistics
shows that as of may this year that's
risen to almost 1200 pounds and our
assessment is it'll rise even further to
around sixteen hundred pounds in your
saving but what's the october price cap
simon you make very good points there i
suppose the question of those upfront
costs and i'm talking about perhaps heat
pumps that can start at around 7 000
pounds for low income households that's
a big chunk of money isn't it
that's absolutely true and
if we think about heat pumps the
government currently has a grant the
boiler upgrade scheme and it can bring
the cost of a heat pump insulation down
to around the same price as a gas boiler
so households who are thinking of having
to replace a gas boiler anyway for
whatever reason now have that option of
a heat pump which is now viable and the
government's working with industry to
bring the actual base cost of the heat
pump down to around the same as a gas
boiler by the end of the decade to make
it even more accessible
and also there are many uh easier
options as well that people can consider
insulation is a really important way of
reducing your gas bills
and there are millions of homes in the
uk that don't have topped up loft
insulation that's a very easy thing to
do
and don't have cow to wall insulation
and these each cost a few hundred pounds
and again for some people that's too
much at the moment
but that's where schemes such as eco the
energy company obligation comes in
it's a scheme uh funded through uh bills
which the government
helps around was more than actually 100
000 homes a year to get better heat
insulation and heating systems and that
can save an average of 600 pounds a year
for poor households under the current
gas prices
simon what is your advice there you've
made some points about insulation and we
did that on the the weekend climate show
with tom heap and he went to visit
someone who was
installing insulation but what advice do
you have for people watching at home
that are thinking about that energy bill
that's coming in what advice can they do
how can they make their home more energy
efficient without breaking the bank
well as i say there are some simple
insulation measures that can still be
done to a lot of homes loft insulation
cavity wall insulation draft exclusion
simple measures um that are relatively
cheap for those who can afford and for
those who are
really struggling and can't afford the
upfront cost then
look into what your energy supplier
can offer through the eco scheme or
possibly through the borrower upgrade
scheme
okay simon cram agree and thank you very
much for joining us on the show today
well let's take a look at today's other
climate news now and climate protesters
have struck for the fifth time in a week
at a major art gallery sticking
themselves to the frame of a copy of
leonardo da vinci's the last supper five
just stop oil supporters attached
themselves to the frame at the royal
academy in central london it comes as
six people believed to be from the same
group were charged over track invasion
at the beginning of the british grand
prix at silverstein
an energy super hub opens today in
oxford designed to decarbonize the city
by providing rapid charging for dozens
of electric vehicles at any one time
now the site combines europe's most
powerful ev charging hub with the
world's largest hybrid battery and is
powered by renewable energy now the
project is part of a planned nationwide
network of super hubs focusing on
reducing carbon emissions from transport
to support uk's clean energy transition
meanwhile sales of battery electric
vehicles in the uk have grown by more
than 14
in a month but continuing supply chain
shortages are affecting the production
of plug-in hybrid vehicles with sales
falling by more than a third there
the queen's property manager has mapped
five areas of the coast off cornwall and
wales which could be developed for
offshore wind projects now the crown
estate identified areas with deeper
water and higher winds which are
suitable for floating rather than the
traditional wind farms now the plan is
to deliver four gigawatts of offshore uh
floating wind power to almost four
million homes by 2035.
and gardeners are being urged to plant
with climate change in mind the royal
horticultural society's planet-friendly
garden highlights solutions to help the
climate crisis including allowing lawns
to go brown in summer rather than
watering and planting trees and hedges
to help store carbon
now as many as 50 000 people are facing
evacuation as severe rain continues to
fall around the australian city of
sydney experts say climate change has
made the rain much worse after years
worth of rain fell in three days in some
regions our correspondent nicole johnson
is in the town of windsor near sydney
and she sent this update
a rescue on the outskirts of sydney this
family believed they could handle the
flood but the water rose so fast before
they knew it the only way out was by
boat waking up at about 2am and seeing
water creeping up to the house it was
it was difficult sleeping but uh yeah no
it's it's definitely scary especially
with kids
already this year there's been multiple
floods in new south wales
and people are tired of it flood fatigue
there is coveting this flood fatigue at
the moment with me
that's what i'm feeling the the two
words to describe it it's just
i'm just tired of the floods more than
30 000 people have been evacuated from
homes in and around sydney
or have been warned to get ready for it
as yet again australia's east coast is
battered by rain
a month's worth of it in only two days
it's incredible uh in the last well 18
months we've had three major flood
events in this area and we're talking
about water depths getting way above
head level um in some areas and you know
multiple people having to be evacuated
animals needing to be rescued and also
people as well
wild weather saw a cargo ship stuck
without power
and drifting towards rocky sea cliffs
a helicopter rescue had to be aborted
eventually it was towed away from danger
this major bridge on the outskirts of
sydney has been lost under a mile wide
river and with the flood waters still
rising people are bracing themselves for
even more homes to go under
so they're getting ready
moving whatever they can to higher
ground
or a shipping container
this is an area prone to flooding
but not this often
keith levy moved in here six months ago
since then
four floods
the ground floor is under a metre of
muddy water
he's given up bothering to pump it out
is this climate change
i think partially i think there's a lot
of factors i think damn management as
well is
the cause of what's also going on and
also the human footprint we're putting
on
the area as well
with barely time to recover from one
flood the region is hit with another
it's been called sydney's new normal
but nothing feels normal about this
nicole johnston sky news
sydney
um before we go we want your climate
questions by the way anything that's
ever mystified you or whatever you want
to get to the bottom of you can scan the
qr code on your screen right now and can
send us your questions some of which
will be answered on our new weekend
climate show hosted by the environment
broadcaster and author tom heap and
you'll be able to watch that on saturday
and sunday at 3 30 here on sky news